aquí nos piden encontrar dos por efe de
88 por g de 8 y aquí tenemos las
gráficas de ambas funciones esta es la
función gx y ésta fx así que pues vamos
a encontrar cuáles son los valores en
estos puntos de x en cada una de estas
funciones veamos efe de 8 vamos a buscar
en el eje de las x nuestro valor 8 que
es este y nuestra función efe que es
esta de aquí abajo vemos que el valor
cuando x es igual a 8 es menos 6
este valor es menos 6
el g8 cuanto es bueno tenemos este mismo
valor en x8 pero ahora lo vamos a buscar
en la función g vamos hacia la función
de x valuada en 8 es este punto y nos
lleva a 7 positivo
este valor es 7 bueno ahora vamos a
resolver todo esto nos dicen que es 2
-6 esto es por menos 6
8 por el v8 que encontramos es 7 x 7
ok 2 x menos 6 es menos 12
y 8 por 7 56 56 56
12 56 - 12
es 44
es 44 esta respuesta es igual a 44 y con
esto hemos terminado